we've got to get americans back to work  if you're able bodied you don't have  young children  you know incapacity dependent get to  work right just go stop being lazy if  you're not handicapped if you don't have  a disability if you don't have a  physical issue i get i mean maybe they  would consider mental issues too i don't  know that's a touch and go with  republicans they claim to care about  mental health but then they don't seem  to you got to get to work because  nobody's working these days and it's  part of the culture and the economic  policy of biden and then you look at the  unemployment rate and you see that the  unemployment rate right now  is essentially as low as it's been  since the early 1970s you have to go i  mean okay you've had this brief period  in 2019  and then you've got to go all the way  back  to the early 1970s to find a period  during which unemployment was this low